uh leaves time our first speaker is
speaking on towards peanuti galenke from
extended fragile lower bounds thank you
so
this is a joint work with uh
which we investigated the possibility of
separating by proving the extended
trigger lower bounds
one of the most basic facts and group
complexity says that and the equals
currently if and only if there is a
polynomial polynomial bounded
prepositional proof system
efficiently by clues of polynomial size
so this tells us that
approach the emperor's quantity problem
and the p-resultant problem
by analyzing complexity of prepositional
proofs
you can first try to prove lower bounds
on length of Blues in resolution then
proceed with increasingly more and more
powerful systems
and so on with hope of eventually
understanding why there is no
prepositional per system which produce
all the authorities efficiently
this approach is sometimes referred to
as the Google program
however the term crackle program
is slightly controversial
as far as I know neither cook nor
Freckle advocated for it
in any case over the years
okay
let this or this group complexity of
this cook record program became very
influential and eventually one of the
most developed approaches to the
resumpty program
so there I would like to focus on one
particle criticism of this program
you can immediately erase the following
compliant
even if they succeed improving lower
bounds for a very strong resolution
growth systems
even if we approve over bounds for an
infinite hierarchy of the strongest
propositional persistence you can
imagine
we have no guarantee that we average the
point of understanding of proposition
persistence
in particular even if you prove extended
fragile lower bounds which is nowadays
recognized as extremely challenging
government problem
they might not be able to conclude that
peace differences they don't know how to
derive such a connection
there are several results in proof
complexity which have similar form
for example lifting theorems provide the
way to derive monotone circular advance
from lower bounds for weak prepositional
product systems like resolution
in the algebraic setting we know how to
you know that the lower bounds for the
eye doctor systems IPS would separate BP
and BNP
and more generally a lower Bound for the
proof system are would imply the
separation of TNN is consistent with the
corresponding theory of boundary
diaphratic Dr using the standard
correspondence between user theories and
proportional systems
however no generic value deriving
explicit lower bounds for unrestricted
Boolean circuits from lower bounds for
concrete preposition for systems of our
interests has been discolored
in fact it's probably fair to say that
this is uh
no one improved complexity really works
on
such question this is not considered as
an approachable problem
what I want to show you today is that uh
actually this problem sits in between
two important worlds which are on the
Collision Course
and uh once these results Collide
through complexity the collapse as well
in the signs that lower bounds for
concrete propositional persistence
will imply that is different from MP or
even phrase it counterpositively the
equality of pnmp will imply the concrete
propositional Pro system is polynomial
bounds
now in order together we need to start
with the related question of independent
interests
one of the first things you learn when
studying mathematical logic is the truth
and probability of different emotions
mathematical statement can be true and
it doesn't have to be plural
well we have completely theorems for
certain weeks but multiple statements it
would be unprecedented
to have them for big mathematical
problems it will be unprecedented if a
significant conjecture implied its own
probability
but as we know the previous anti program
is different from other mathematical
questions it's so fundamental that it
can't be ignored and it's so loaded with
connections to foundations of
mathematics that perhaps it could
possess that you property of soft
probability
um in fact I will show you now that uh
under a certain possibly looking
assumption
there is
a form of such soft probability
to explain this we need to consider a
question about the about feasible
witnessing of the separation of the
Olympics
so let's uh
Define this predicate start an x y
which will encode a statement that
prepositional formal acts n is Satisfied
by assignment life
okay so this is a polynomial and
predicate it says that given a
prepositional form of X upon n
and assignment y the assignment y
satisfies the preposition for one
now let's assume that uh start is
actually hard for cities of size and the
10K
this is the case then
every Circuit of size enter the case
first to search for satisfying
assignments of satisfied performance
approach
if there was a circuit of size Center
Decay which was which would be able to
find also for every satisfiable formula
some satisfying assignment of the
formula we could use this circuit to
construct the circle which is not much
bigger and so sad besides start
efficient
so we know that every small circuit
first to search for satisfying
assignments of satisfiable performance
but uh
our question here is can we witness this
fact feasible in the following stance
is there a polynomial and function f
which given
a small CPC of size n to Decay
outputs two strings F1 C and f2c such
that advanced C is a preposition formula
of London
which is Satisfied by the assignment f2c
but at the same time circuit C given
just the prepositional formula
he's not able to find any satisfying
assignment of this formula
so again assuming there's that sad is
hard we want to conclude that there is a
polynomial and functional which can
witness this part in the sense that
given a small circuits the function
finds an error of the circuits you can
find a satisfiable for one
together with its satisfying the Simon
so that
you could see
cannot find any satisfying assignment of
this phone
would you be happy with the
probabilistic polynomial time left
[Laughter]
I mean
outcomes
then you get you can get triggers
but there is
okay
so sure what is the second line set so
it's F1 of c and then F2 of C
what is F1 and F2 yeah
sorry I didn't hear the function f is
foreign
yeah
the oldest we only heard about uniform
lower bounds
and can you come up with an algorithm
that prints out almost there okay
so what we know is that understandable
ass assumptions you can actually
construct whatever the functions
if you assume that uh H is one way
function
and you are given a CPC of size npdk
you can randomly generate a
and write down the prepositional formula
which can cause this statement that h x
equals h a
in this propositional formula
x r the only three variables
and is fixed string is a fixed bit
string
so this formula asks whether there is
some sine of x which satisfies the
equality of h x equals h
now if your circuit say was able to find
satisfying assignment of this form of
its significant probability it would
break the value function
so it's not going to happen and we hold
it with high probability this is going
to be the right position formula
which is going to be also satisfiable
when you are going to no respect to be
the satisfying assignment
so this is how you can Witness
probabilistically
you can construct such polio such
functional if you are allowed to use
random units and understand that
assumptions if you assume that
exponential time is higher than average
for sub-expression size circuits
you
you can be random as this construction
and cons and obtain deterministic
polynomial function of this problem
this is what we were referring to
like that
I'm not happy with this construction
what I want is really to construct such
a polynomial function life
just assuming that satisfied I don't
want to assume anything more I mean
anything more than this technology I
want to witness essentially
now there are this uh
similar witnessing theorems in uniform
sudden following the Paradigm of good
front shelter and tashma
but they actually do not seem to give us
this kind of implication
and
I'll try to explain this in a little
later
now I will slightly change this question
because the actual question we are going
to be interested in is slightly
different
I want to know if there is a polynomial
and function f such that the following
prepositional formula W can f is
the preposition formula has two digits
so let me jump says that uh
if a proportional format X is Satisfied
by sine and Y
then the circuit C can find satisfying
assignment of
Revolution formats
so in this life design we have three
variables x y and C
C is supposed to be a circuit of size n
to the k
and it's represented by polynomial
three variables
encoding a potential Circuit of size
the radish junk is just a copy of this
conjunction on the previous line
it says that my function f finds
satisfying
satisfiable formula together with
satisfying assignments such that
the circuit C cannot find any satisfying
will not find any satisfying assignment
before
this is very similar to the implication
on the previous line
the difference is that
the previous application
if that was easy
I didn't have to construct my poly
modern function I didn't have to do
anything
but
in the second line if I want to
construct polynomial and functional
which satisfies this disjunction
even if satis easy and my function f is
given a circuit C which first to solve
that it's supposed to find an error of
such a circuit
so
this function f has
a bit harder job but the previous
argument which I showed you shows that
uh understand that happens assumptions
there is a column another function which
makes this form a topological as well
yes
by basically that it solves the above in
like the promise like if if C is correct
then it doesn't have to have any
guarantee otherwise it fails yes so the
other way through it is that if C first
Define satisfying assignments or
something
then our functions
okay
we want to say does there exist as such
that uh this is in time for okay
okay
sorry not fixing for some fixed k for
house case to give you the parameter in
the results
foreign
and the system is defined just defined
just like extended trigger but at any
step in your proof you can derive
arbitrary substitutional instance of
this prepositional formula
so since you know that this is a
tautology
this proof system remind remains sound
and it's good crackle because
the function f is in polynomial time so
you can efficiently recognize whether a
prepositional formula is a
substitutional instance
of this
resolution form or W planner
when you write F like this house
extension values okay
so the choice of excellent trigger here
doesn't really matter and it's option of
the stronger system would work very well
I decided to Extended drag it just
because this is the economical
prepositional system
it formalizes visible reasoning and it's
given by
finite circle of sound and educational
complete generation rules
and operated circles instead of for us
now this system has the following nice
property
if you assume that sat is computer by
circus or size and K over 10.
then by search the decision reduction
there is a small circuit of size at the
Decay which is able to
solve the search version of sub it is
able to find satisfying assignments of
satisfied formos
so we can take such circuit
and inside the system you can derive
prepositional formula where instead of
three variable C you have this concrete
circuit series solves up
but now since the circuits is so sad
you know that the right division of this
formula is actually false
notice that the right vision of this
formula doesn't contain essentially any
three variables
so
you can actually refute it feasibly
efficiently inside extension
which means that
you can
conclude the left vision
of this propositional formalhost
this is what I'm referring to this
statement when I'm writing down that
extended
rules efficiently that start is easy
it rules efficiently the left digital on
this one
so this is a form of self probability
assuming just that sat is easy we can
conclude that there are short proofs of
the statement
but this is conditional we need to
assume that we have this autologous W
camera
sorry what is the
obstacle in today's topologies sap and
is indeed predicate which is polynomial
time
um ah the seals
oh my God
so another thing which follows directly
from this is that the system extended
tracker plus wkf is actually important
this is because
if you know inside the system there's
some circuit systems
you can use it to glue all the apologies
more detail we are given a formal file
which is not logical
you can inside extended fragrance
about the circuit C which is so sad
on the mutation of Phi and the circuit
table fail to find will fail to find any
satisfying assignment of this polymer
on fire it's not logical
so we can prove efficiently inside
extension forget this fact
but since extended fragrant was wkf
knows that the circuit C finds some
satisfying assignment if one exists
this system can actually conclude that
negation of Phi
is unsatisfiable
which means that it can conclude that
formal file is topological
this can be done efficiently yes
just based on the above assumption that
that thing's entire EF can prove for a
specific circuit C that it's like you
have a confidency and for this
competition it's safe you can build the
left
the only remaining three variables are
asked about
okay and we get that just from the
assumption that that thing's been taught
based on some external argument just
under these two assumptions
yes
n refers to the length of the X length
of X yes so we are talking about four
months or what and we are asking it
will be given by X is Satisfied by sine
and Y
oh
damage the same like I said if NP is in
peace
equals B
um
yes
it was like NP intersect going to be
functions
so f is
I think that's a session content
this won't be enough
something like short extended further
proof of the definition of the antivirus
so why is impact in this circuits of
segments to it I mean we just need to
evaluate the circuit the given formula
at a lifetime
isn't that
this is
Saturn is the function sat n of X Y is a
Formula but it's being abused and
patiently abused
so you have a witnessing uh everything
will find the satisfying assignment for
every CNF which is a desirable
okay
let's see it works and the right one
says
it is
importance
okay so let's just uh repeat what we
through we show that City will advance
forward to all around so we have this
topologies
the separation of Plenty or more
formally
without a software and uh
Circuit of size and to do Epsilon okay
for some fixed constant Epsilon
now moreover if you assume that this
proposition for once have short extended
for example
you can replace this system by extent
fragrance this is what I wrote down in
the second item
but uh instead of saying that this
preposition formulas have short extent
trigger proofs
reasoning
if you don't know what it is you can
just imagine that I'm assuming that
there are short extensive rules of this
topology
the reason why I'm using S12 is just
that it will help me to illustrate the
importance of our results later
now this is clearly a very generic
theorem we didn't use anything specific
about extended trigger
as I said previously any sufficiently
strong proof system would work very well
here
but the main question is
if we can construct this
proposition formos wknf
you can construct tautologists
we probably believe that such
authorities exist because this wasn't
the case then for each polynomial
functional there would exist some
circuit systems after the function I
wouldn't be able to witness error of the
circuit so this would be like saying
that from the perspective of this
polynomial 10 functions or feasible
observers because NP and they probably
don't tend to believe that this is the
case
I also go to this conditional
construction which gives which implies
that there is such there are such
Technologies the approving this
unconditionally
what's up
it's probably going to be hard because
it would imply new circular amounts
this is actually
not hard to see now
let's assume that for each kid there
exists the polynomial function Maps we
have this topologies
if this is the case then we can apply it
here and one
and the
first item of the theorem one says that
if for HK this system is not polynomial
bounded
then South is hard for people
so in this case we are done
but suppose that this is not the case
suppose that
there is some character that
the system is polynomial bounded then
anti-cost currently
and we know that this implies that Annex
is harder for people
so in both case is a good new
circuit board one explicit circular one
is it correct that the tautologic hood
of
wknf only depends on whether you have
see whether you have C as s or f as in
the
as in your definition it has nothing to
do with the Delta logic which is whether
it is true or not whether F exists or
not yeah
I just wanted to make sure that it's not
about the the topological battery
whether it exists yes and more formally
I'm asking for the existence of
functionality support
polynomial size which is stronger
yeah I think you should be able to do
this in the same argument
you know because the consequences so
that mentioned essentially
you know something like equality
I'm not aware of other consequences
Okay so
it actually
multiply this theorem slightly so that
we avoid this problem of deriving new
nonlinear for circuit lower bounds
because
we want to conclude just that is
different from NP then we can slightly
relax this condition
if you look at the definition of WQ and
F you can actually modify it so that
instead of considering
circuit C we consider Universal Turing
motion which receives login bits an
Enterprise this login bits as a
description of a turing machine and then
symbolize the printing machine on input
X
then our witnessing function is
asked to witness errors of such touring
machines described by Logan bits which
might be potentially easier
the whole argument here will still go
through
in particular if you assume just the P
equals NP then for some sufficiently big
log big length n
the algorithm which source sat will
appear
will be described by this first log and
bits
and uh
our proof system extends trigger plus
wkf with modified for my wkf you'll be
able to simulate it
this is significant also because we have
this uh
uniform witnessing functions
in
witnessing functions in uniform setting
following this just the instructions
but uh
actually it's still not clear how to
obtain such a witnessing function even
in the universe setting
this is because what a good running
shelter and chashma did is that they
showed that is different from NP then
for every turing machine I am and for
every input line and you can come up
with three formulas such as your touring
machine and first on one of these
formulas
but they didn't construct satisfying
assignments of these four moves
so
even if we know that our algorithm fails
on one of these formulas if it fails at
all we don't know how to verify it
efficiently because we don't have
satisfying assignments
there is an extension of this work which
constructs also satisfying assignments
but uh
it actually relies crucially on the
assumption that is different from NP
which implies that uh every turing
machine fails on infinitely many input
lengths and this is something about the
kind of effort in our setting
so this so it's still open how to
construct such polynomials and functions
even if you restrict the number of the
amount of uniformity non-uniformity of
the circles
what would that give
a good word
then I would construct this
pathologist and I would prove
unconditionally that
uh
this proposition Pro system has this
property that if it's not polynomial
bounded it's different from it
so this will be a huge thing if you
could do it
now
I'm going to show you that if you allow
this function f to be computable in none
of binary from circuits then you can
construct such functions unconditionally
and uh
I will write down the specific formula
precisely here I will denote it by Alpha
I send now so this is going to play the
role of the formal W kind of and the
former Alpha asan
is going to have two digits again the
left design is very similar to the
previous formula the last Edition in the
previous formula it says that if formal
X is Satisfied by Simon wide and some
circuit B can find satisfying assignment
of the four one
and this time the circuit B is going to
be fixed
I'm going to fix it in a second
but uh I write Vision says that every
circuit C first or so sad
on some input from set a
and this set a is going to be again
fixed so I will fix some cpb I will fix
some set a or size polynomial in US
this predicate sat and Z is going to be
just a fixed bit
it's going to be zero or one depending
on whether the formula Z is satisfiable
and the only three variables in these
formulas in this formula are x y and C
so in order to Define this finish the
definition of this formula I need to
specify A and B
so let's start with the definition of a
in order to define a I will use a
theorem of Lipton and yank from tinnitus
if I assume that sat is hard for a
surface of size s cubed then I know that
for each Circuit of size s
then I know that there is a polynomial
size set a polynomial in the parameter s
such as for each circuit or size s the
circuit C
first this will start on one of the
inputs from this set Edge
okay so the Assumption says that start
is hard for polynomial circuits which
means that there is some input on the
list of all possible exponential
remaining inputs so that every circuit C
first
sorry for each every for each circuit
there is some input such as the circuit
flows on this input
says that there is a small set of inputs
such as every circuit
first to Source out actually on one of
the inputs from this small set
so if something is hard for a circus of
such a script I will Define my a to be
this set of
so-called anti-checkers
s is going to there is some connection
as is going to be we could you should
imagine that there is
over there
something is not something
uh
well so if salt is hard for certain
skill then
message a in this definition is going to
be the set of answer checks
but if that is easy then I will take
arbitrary Saturday
okay so this specifies the
a now I need to specify this Circle B
and in order to define the circuit b i
define another circuit B Prime which has
the following property it satisfies the
equivalence that that is computed by
circuits of size the skilled if not only
if this concrete circuit B Prime solves
up
so other constructs such a circuits
again I consider two cases either side
is easy for surface of size s cubed then
I have some circuit which solves such so
I can take I can define B Prime to be
the circuit and the Crown's holes
or the other side is hard for circuits
of size a script and then I can take any
circuit
B Prime and the icons is going to be
whole it's going to hold
so in both cases
the consoles
this shows that I can construct the
circuit B Prime and by some standard bio
canonical
decision reduction I can construct the
circuit B from circuit B Prime
this is obviously very non-constructive
trick but it works it gives us this
to such a and b and now I claim that
this formula the resulting form of alpha
s n is tautological
the reason why this is the case is that
is the following consider the
assumption that start is hard for a
series of size SQ in such case I know
that the right Digi angle the formal is
tautological
so the foreign
so I know that the left digital
so this formula is topological
so just like in the case of theorem we
can use it to prove that uh
specific extended trigger lower bounds
would imply that South is hard
if you could show that there are
pathologies without polymer size
extended cracker derivations from this
formulas Alpha
okay and then sub would be hard for
citizer size engine
this is derived in the same way
there are
one
but obviously the problem here is that
we do not know anything about this
essentially
anything about this formal Alpha this is
very non-constructive formula the main
question is is how to make it more
constructive
and I think that the code of the
question is
in proving the theorem of
more constructively
the proof of theorem of returning
requires or uses Minimax theorem or
similar methods
so I think that what would what would be
needed here is to prove this feasible
Amino experience more constructively yes
issues
okay what I'm asking for is
an episiore
if you don't know what this episode
precision
there are many clues of Linux there are
so many there is sound
aware of it
but
Okay so
these are some initial observations and
now now we will use these observations
to show the world of some classical
questions and complex disappear
and the questions which we'll consider
are questions about collapsing internet
as well
as well as describe possible scenarios
of average cost complexity
I don't know describe them in detail
we've seen many thoughts which did very
nicely during this program
instead I will give you a couple of
statements which correspond to such
purposes
the first statement I want to consider
is construction of one way functions
from the separation of pnnp
so this is often described as the Holy
Grail of cryptography
and what we can show is that
we could prove that when a functions
follow from
the separation of PNP inside S12 and if
you could prove inside sn2 that
exponential time is hard on average for
some exponential side circuits then
extended regular bonds would imply that
is different from NP
so
okay
yeah I've not demanded the entirely
contract
yes
sorry Miss what was the comment so it
could actually conclude and possible
relax this uh
requirement that uh explanation of that
there's a lower Bound for a specialized
actions
and replace if you replace the system in
the conclusion
by System extend fragrance
plus the tautology which postulates
hardness of some function in expandable
so we just assume that exponential
damage had a leverage for such exposure
specifics then you could
still conclude
similar statement people just need to
replace the system by something slightly
stronger this is still a quick recovery
system under this assumption
in fact
if your final goal is to prove that
peace different from employed and
this kind of for free to assume that
explanation that exponential time is
hard on average for stocks as circuits
because if this is not the class that is
different from NP automatically
so the first Assumption of this theorem
is kind of for free
the main Assumption of this theorem is
really the fact that we can
prove that money functions follow from
it being different from NP inside this
one too
and just like in the case of theorem one
this is very generic theorem we could
replace example by essentially any
Theory I could use here even set the
reservesc so you could really resolve
this Holy Grail of cryptography inside
set theory using any kind of mathematics
essentially this would still have this
dramatic consequence for proof
complexity the lower Bound for concrete
propositional Pro System would imply
that is different from
by the way uh if the circuits are not
uniform in the first sentence yes this
shouldn't it be known
oh yes
um
yes but uh
to help us
see what the argument online specific
into one and
foreign
[Music]
oh
the second assumption that S12 through
one light functions that's a that's an
input accident that's a set of well this
is actually a simple example and I
should qualify here that we actually
acquire polynomial time reduction
which uh thanks a certain breaking by
the function and consider substitute
which is also and the correctness of
this reduction should be approvable
uh we probably already see how to prove
this theorem I already gave you this
conditional witnessing function
Al with a single file
elements of stuff if you have Runway
function H and you assume that
exponential time is hard on average for
sub expansion size if it's
then uh you get a polynomial function
which Witnesses errors of polymers
recipients so what we do is that we
formalize this inside S12
now additionally we assume that uh S12
proves that uh
this financial time is hard on average
for sub expansion so I think it's
tomorrow we assume that we can build one
function from the assumption that is
different from NP so we come back if we
combine these things
You can conclude that uh inside S12
either P equals NP or the recipient
function which witnesses that is
different from it
this is really like uh
going inside S12 that this propositional
formosw can have our topological so we
can
similar the proof of the theorem
this is
a high level idea it's simple of course
if you want to make it formal we need to
deal with some technicalities in
particular for example in order to
formalize the statement you need to use
approximate Counting
so what we do is that we use the theory
APC one
uh to do that since S12 proves that
exponential time is hard knowledge for
Starbucks specialized circuits we know
that actually S12 simulates episode and
we can do everything inside S12
foreign
can you say it again the last video so
we have this assumption that I want to
prove that exponential time is hard on
average for service management
this assumption actually implies that as
one possible it's like this okay so we
can afford to use the machinery
so it is
as well
for example we can replace the
assumptions as we can build lovely
functions from from the separation of
PS2
the assumption that uh and the runway
functions exist or
it's possible to learn polyamasa
circuits by sub-exponential size
circuits the membership queries over the
uniform distribution it's a non-trivial
confidence
it's a non-trivial error parameter
difficult
okay so what is this disjunction this
disjunction
uh you could prove such a thing this
would effectively rule out pestilence
out of Imperials it would mean that you
can either either build safe
cryptography or have some magical
algorithm which learns people
but if you could throw this inside this
one too
then specific extended trigger load ones
would separate pnnp
specifically if you could prove that
there are hard Boolean functions such
that extend tracker cannot prove that
these functions are hard this would
imply that is different from it
and the proof of this
is a very similar to the proof of the
previous theorem the only difference is
that now we assume that we can build one
way function from the assumption that
learning is hard
so here we concluded either learning is
easy or you can witness the statistics
are so P equals empty then we can inside
the theory as one two
prove that some learning algorithm works
and then we can use this learning
algorithm to prove circular bounds
inside the theory
another statement which we can prove is
uh
relation is about the relation between
cryptography and automatability we can
we can replace the
previous assumption by the assumption
that S12 proves that either binary
functions exist or extended frame is
automatable
automatability is another Central
concept improved complexity improved
system is automatable there is a
polynomial time algorithm
which given a form of I finds a proof
of the form of I in polynomial time with
respect to the shortest
blue integration system
s
you know it's safe cryptography yeah
functions then uh if you have value
assumptions then you have to talk about
now we're going in the right direction
is cryptography then it must be through
when it comes that's what it seems to be
said
I will survive this
this
is okay
if you're not right cryptography then it
must be that equals one attention
so what we are asking for in the next
step
is to
flash a problem setup we know that if
extended frag is automatable then we can
break standard hardness we can break RSI
specifically protocols but we do not
know how to break the general
cryptographic assumption
and just an automatic algorithm
but what we are asking for here is the
opposite application assuming that you
can break Runway functions you want to
automate extended fragrance and in fact
it could be sufficient to automated on
we want to base Runway functions on
not automatability
you can prove this inside this one too
then
you get the proof complexity collapse
so the here you change it to a circuit
law of arms
EF does not prove a circuit level but
before this it was for any yes this is a
stronger assumption specifically about
how to get settled
foreign
because
during this program we've seen many
talks that attempted to attack various
eliminations of importance as worlds
and I personally spend like we are
trying to show the dichotomy between
cryptography and learning
you already know that learning
algorithms follow from natural proofs so
all that is needed to get such a
dichotomist to show that you can
construct natural proofs if you assume
that you can break out prg's
cryptographic prgs so you assume that
for every PMG there is a small circuit
which so which breaks the prg
I still feel like this might be an
approachable problem
perhaps there is a way how to prove that
Google program is viable
but there's always a more pessimistic
possibility is that the corresponding
problems in uh learning theory and
cryptography are just too hard
and indeed our results can be
interpreted as an Evidence against
further hardness
but in any case uh with complexity does
it in between these two Imports which
are on the Collision Course and this is
a new fundamental connection between
logic cryptography and learning
thank you
[Applause]
questions
these results they're like you have
these strict assumptions would imply
that if
uh status small circuits that EF is
pre-bounded like is there any sense in
which if you make these assumptions that
unconditionally they imply some weak
optimality property of extended frigate
or like it's always they don't imply
anything interesting about the power of
the positively about the power of
extended Freddie in the case where set
does require large circuits that
question would make any sense like uh
in the sense improving this like
collapse like it's like this conditional
thing that if you have that extended
frigate is like uh implicationally as a
food system but uh but like it's
unbounded if you only if any system is
unbounded uh but they don't seem to
imply
a little bit of optimality it's like
okay
the approach
um
so it does even indication regardless of
whether sponsors
notion
so those burgers in some big sense of
you know
you mentioned that the problem of
probability of the young literal result
in APC one
uh my ABC one would APC 2 be okay
for being improval of the I imagine that
as I guess that we can prove this
theorem of it right now inside episode